alors là
mais le père noël c'est moi
des cadeaux
j'ai cru que c'était un frère moi je
suis
le père noël est trop vieux pour parler
pour aller faire de l'acte sur la glace
les enfants sont absolument émerveillés
ils veulent toucher le père noël le voir
lui parler lui poser des questions
en combien de temps va durer mon voyage
quand est-ce que je commence à préparer
les cadeaux en sont mais reine qu'est ce
que je leur donne à manger
à vandaliser si maintenant les n'en est
pas encore là parce que c'est bien tu
m'as tu m'as dit mes parents ils peuvent
pas jeter tout et voilà lanceront par
nourrir
tu es joie de ses parents
moi ils croivent obama le souhaitez par
mois y croire au père noël comme je veux
y croire j'y crois j'y crois pas moi je
prends pas
on jamais
je dis pas que photo ci contre le joueur
savary
c'est bien de le savoir patronage
à voir le cadeau
en fait on a fait croire que cette
légende existait et sais c'est pas bien
de dire après les père noël n'existe pas
a dit tu as fait trop c'est qu'un petit
mensonge pour les enfants mais bon c'est
pas grave